hey Lucas pay oh goody goody goody goody
goody goody goody good you good you good
to go to community but they're gonna
gonna gonna gonna gonna go to well my
god the lag did you do this every time
yeah the sauna sauna sauna my father's
bones the wall there daddy what do I do
speak to the skeleton in the wall he
knows all
I got it did it what no no you must
believe in yourself I'm believing so
hard right now ah I believe you my god
careful senpai ha ha I had it you did
know how to have it totally it would
have been down when I jumped that yeah
oh my god ha ha here we go oh gosh I
don't jump up me [ __ ] what
smacks impossible ah the actual gun I
think it killed you okay Oh what do i do
what do i do it just why do I do
run it run do a run small jump behind
you gotta get out of there Gary
you must go yeah I will not move off
without you you're gonna make it out of
here soldier you gotta keep going how
would I tell your wife I made a promise
I would take care of your America
America and it's plinian and just
chilling and it's floating
just chilling so happy sitting that
low-voc oh no my friend Jade yep [ __ ] oh
oh I just put my foot my life in God's
hands and he delivered [ __ ] you we had a
lujah lujah
what that [ __ ] does happen sorry buddy
looks like it was your time today there
but [ __ ] ow
oh god baby that's how much blood
everywhere tomato basil sauce too much
tomato sauce okay so we gotta wait this
lady to go back but hey maybe we don't I
don't know cow in it rocks Ninio jump
dodged a bullet
I don't know
yeah just like back in high school in
the G bar reliving all my by young
fantasies that the teenage eggs